we begin with breaking news from Israel
where Benjamin Netanyahu and his
right-wing allies have secured a clear
majority with all the votes counted the
former prime minister's block has won 64
seats out of 120. current leader yair
lepids Alliance has 51 seats and the
caretaker prime minister has conceded
Netanyahu is already the longest-serving
Israeli Prime Minister he's been at
leader for 15 years over multiple terms
but is still facing corruption charges
let's bring in Stephanie Decker who
joins us live now from West Jerusalem
hello there Steph Lupita's concession
paves the way for netanyahu's return to
power
yes I think there is no doubt now that
it will be Benjamin Netanyahu who will
be um you know tasked with forming an
ex-government because there's a process
now that takes place basically uh they
will hold consultations with the
president at the end of next week or
parties and then the President appoints
the person best place if you will uh to
form a government I think we're under no
doubt now that that is going to be
Benjamin Netanyahu he always said when
he was ousted from Power last year that
he was going to do everything to bring
down the government
um and to come back to Power and to come
back into the prime minister's seat he's
done it he's back with a vengeance he
brings with him uh the right the most
right-wing coalition government that
Israel
um has seen and I think it's going to be
interesting now in terms of once those
negotiations uh start and that's going
to take another 28 days from once
um Netanyahu is tasked with forming a
government how the cabinet is going to
look like because you have characters
that has been part of his Coalition like
item or bengaver extremely controversial
far right wing ultra-nationalist
religious ultra-nationalist
um who has had been demanding the uh
public post of the minister of security
which put him in charge of the police
there have been rumors as well that
Netanyahu is not going to give him that
but there are going to be demands of
senior cabinet Ministries so how that is
going to be allocated we won't know at
least for another month or so but what
is clear is that it looks like Benjamin
Netanyahu has done exactly what he
promised and that is to return to power
so Steph what do the next few days look
like will there be an official
announcement of the winner
well as I said so at the end of net of
this week next week he will prime
minister well I'm to call you and prime
minister already he is essentially he
will be but he will be uh visiting with
Isaac Herzog the president along with
the olapid all the leaders and the
parties there'll be consultations and
basically the way
um politics works here is that then down
to the president to appoint the person
he believes has the best chances of
forming a government well there are no
questions anymore that it is going to be
Benjamin Netanyahu we know that last
year certainly here lapid was very much
um I I think special in how he
orchestrated a coalition that range from
left to right with the first
palestinian-israeli party in government
as well all coming together for one
purpose to get rid of Benjamin Netanyahu
but there are ideological differences
didn't remain it didn't last more than
just about a year
um and so what we do expect uh by the
end of next week potentially early the
week after for Isaac hairstyle to
appoint Benjamin Netanyahu as the man to
form a next government and then those
negotiations will start as to how the
cabinet and how the government will look
like and once that that happens then
Israel will know exactly what their next
government will look like so there's
still a political process involved it's
still going to take some time but again
very clear that uh you know unless
there's any major surprises that
Benjamin Netanyahu will once again be
prime minister great thank you so much
for the update to Stephanie Decker live
for us there in West Jerusalem thank you